Millennials happy Monday welcome back to
the morning toast I'm so excited to be
kicking off my week because like Jackie
is always holding down the fort she is
the anchor of this ship because I'm
always like gallivanting being a Comique
and she's always here taking the guest
host and it looks so fun and I never get
to guess with anyone and Jackie's on
vacation this entire week so I have so
many fun guest co-host today and
tomorrow I have my good friend radios
host to the stars
Taylor Stryker here hi girl hi I'm so
excited because this is such a great
week for us because we have not like
worked together in so long cuz we were
both going through just like stuff and
you have never been on the Cho so you
used to be under breath yeah this is
your first time on the show so we have
you two days one cuz I just feel like
you're really good host and it is hard
to find people who are just like I don't
have to work overtime so I get you to
talk do you know we're all no you do not
yeah I'll just sit here and you talk
just half of me if I talk to my dad I
get criticisms all the time cyclist is
there like to him can you let your
co-hosts talk yeah no I literally cannot
stop talking over people so justice for
whoever I listen to this episode and the
second reason is because I just want to
catch up you have so much going on and
we just like we're friends so she when
she needed two episodes because I didn't
want to find someone else and I like you
and I and we're good so we are going to
as always you know be talking about
everything that happened this weekend
but we're also just gonna catch up you
know what I was on Taylor's show today
yeah and I'm on tomorrow as well are we
yep so - oh the show is from 8:00 to
10:00 and then she's here 10:30
obviously and she actually said that
when she started her new job she did it
from 8:00 to 10:00 so that she could
co-host the toast yeah hello haha so
thoughtful I would like never think of
someone else that much it's also I feel
like there's like a respect in this
business like you don't like going to
someone's timezone I mean if you did I
wouldn't have been mad and trust your
time spot is way better than mine I'm
getting really sick of the 8 I got
really sick I've been sick for like five
weeks I'm better now I'm not going to do
um but I'm gonna be like hacking
throughout this but I said one of my
listeners was like what are you doing
like you need to be a morning radio move
later and I'm like I don't know I'm
considering but I think that's my round
sweet spot and me and Jackie always say
that when we wait
yeah we want to die and it's torture but
like when we're doing the show it's like
so invigorating and then we really get
like hyped up there like when the show's
over I'm ready for my full day totally
it's a great way to start the home yeah
of course I'm ready much for my full day
to go home and answer help emails on my
tech support I'm like literally a
one-woman show I've got people helping
me but I'm I'm answering those tech
health questions torture Oh bane of my
existence so if you want to listen to
some really premium content honestly
today's episode tomorrow's episode it's
like a little funnier but today we
really got deep so I actually cried but
only for like a second always makes fun
of me when I cry snitches hear about the
way you guys as a she's on her snitch
cam so make sure you're tuning into the
stitch cam but if you do want to hear me
and Taylor go pretty deep about some of
the stuff that happened a couple months
ago with you and with me it's a really
good I think it's really gonna up
something it's still funny so oh good
tell us record calm Taylor sure to calm
it is subscription-based but the
beautiful thing is I also have a podcast
taste of Taylor that's free subscribe on
iTunes and it'll be there right and it
will be there this Wednesday fantastic
hello so if times are tough don't worry
yeah but without further ado it is my
absolute pleasure to deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay
so Jackie usually picks the stories and
like I just like to stroll in and I had
to pick the stories this morning it's
like a lot of work because we really
always want to have like a well rounded
shot I wanna only talk about like Ariana
and Pete but like you guys have such
good news
but at the others on the other hand like
all I want to do is talk about Ariana
and Pete you know so so bear with me
our first story gets do with Cara
Delevingne it's a two to fold story and
I picked this story in particular for
you okay because okay so better that's
me Anne wait sorry I need to backtrack
yes exactly yeah it i use a backtrack
taylor's tracker I feel like we
definitely a big crossover in audience
but then we have a lot of new listeners
who might not know who you are so tell
us record you were at sirius radio for
how long oh my god 11 years and you had
like a huge show I'm like I feel like
before words more like boss about it I
mean work know like I can swear right
yeah I don't like [ __ ] that I'm like I
had the second to dr. Schlessinger
highest-rated show I saw the numbers
people someone gave them to me I saw
that [ __ ] how many people were listening
today oh my god
like hundreds and hundred
hundreds of thousand that is so great
actually we got projections from like I
mean the numbers are funny there because
they don't have like hard hard core
numbers the lowest I got was like
minimum 500,000 and the highest I got
was like 1 point 2 to point 3 but I was
on the air for like 11 years culpa and
we had Cosmo magazine behind us for a
while so but I was a morning show on
stars and then Jenny McCarthy was on
after me my numbers were better than
hers um and yeah we we crushed we did
really really well yeah and you were
there for so long and I used to come it
was so fun so far and now you spend out
independently cuz it was some drums
there was I got fired honestly I got
fired too right and I used to say like
I've never been fired but now it's
something that's had that has happened
to me why couldn't I get fired from like
a [ __ ] waitressing job right or like a
job where I got severance you know I did
not get that rinse but I feel it so I
was of course like so depressed and I
was also in a non-compete for three
months which sucked and you couldn't
talk about it and I couldn't talk about
I was supposed to be a year why my
lawyer said don't talk until we get like
the you're clear to work in X amount of
time so they could have had me no
severance for a year well that would
have been that would have been torture
me barista Yeller shocker yeah I'm like
I'm gonna have to get like a job I like
I'm gonna have to get like a job job a
real job which I would have but I mean
whatever it would have sucked
actually I probably just would have
lived off my divorce settlement said
okay so you have the most interest as
much as everyone thinks it is and you
have the most interesting backstory and
I think that's what will you're talking
about on your show this morning is like
when we first met like I meet a lot of
people I go and like we both like I meet
a lot of people go a lot of people shows
but I don't like become friends with any
of them but like we really connected and
I think I was like so intrigued by your
story cuz you're just a regular girl you
did what you thought you had to do got
married to a cute Jewish boy like that's
what everyone thinks and how many years
were you married for we were just shy of
five years when we got divorced and
that's rated and now you're madly in
love with your best friend Taylor a girl
oh girl and by the way they literally
couldn't be cuter her Taylor it's like
it's so stunning and gorgeous like so
tall and skinny and blonde and like I
want to date her and the fact that both
in your names are Taylor it just gives
me like Taylor Swift Taylor Lautner
vibes and I just love it and tell me
about that cuz you were super brave in
the sense you were on the radio and all
this was happening when you got divorced
and when you
kind of like came out you did it to your
audience so I used to always refer to
like my radio show as reality radio
because I wanted to be Army on the TV
but nobody cast me so I'm like haha
I'll make reality radio a thing and it
also I work with this girl who was a
super know-it-all and more well read
than I was I mean maybe she wasn't like
smarter in every way but like I
certainly felt like she was [ __ ] hate
smart people like smart people right and
so this girl was like always on my ass
like it was called wake up Oh Taylor but
she wanted it to be her shawl I'm liking
your own job totally so anyway but we
were like fighting over my co-host she
wanted him was whole thing so I was like
this [ __ ] always wants up me so what
can I do that's what what can I talk
about that she doesn't know anything
about oh my god she can't tell me I'm
yeah i'ma write about me totally and I
start talking all about my life and that
was like a very Howard thing too and so
that's why it's like reality radio right
but because of that one [ __ ] started to
hit the fan I've been American in my
marriage I really and I mean I would
complain about was bend I'm gonna call
him all the time but like really silly
like bickering classic old married
couples so yeah like like you know The
Odd Couple yeah like what sitcoms are
based on yeah and so but like I never
got to the nitty-gritty and so when then
the divorce came out my lawyer was like
you cannot talk about this on air if you
do and you go to court the judge is
going to destroy and riot so then I had
to be super quiet but like I was still
on social media and we go through this
yeah and like looking at apartments and
so people were like what's going on I
couldn't talk about it people like I'm
gonna stop listening Chiefy tell us so I
was like you guys are screaming a second
give me a minute I'll talk when I can so
I was able to talk I guess it was like
July mid-july
I think the divorce is finalized so
that's when I was allowed to talk so I
made the divorce announcement meanwhile
by then I was already dating Taylor
right cuz divorces takes so long and
they're separations like this second we
were separated was Ben was like on a
dating thing yeah yeah yeah no no that's
that's why I had this huge problem with
LuAnn and Bethenny last season like
LuAnn saying that Bethenny was dating a
married man when like he was separated
for over a year like once you're
separated you can date you brokens up
yeah but much like we're gonna like try
to work on it but legally separated
which I totally donors yep I completely
agree do so that's where I was like and
but Taylor and I were still super new
and so I was like my onions can
handle I'm getting a divorce and I'm
dating a girl they'll a [ __ ] die it's
a lot so and I was too like dealing with
stuff with my parents about her and like
I'm telling friends so like about an
entire year later I finally announce to
my show that I was so epic I know it was
scary I cried afterwards I was like that
was a mistake I should know secret yeah
I freaked you know I have a question for
you mind talking about that don't know
because I always feel like I am like
this likes really confident strong
course and I'm like if I was gay I would
like literally shout it from the
rooftops sometimes I wish I was gay cuz
like I just feel like I want to be gay
and I just want to tell her and I always
wonder how someone like me would come
out because we're so similar yes were
you were you nervous were you in the
like a closet for a long period of time
I mean I guess I would say that I was
like closeted for about a year cuz from
like divorce announcement I guess it
would be like a year and like a couple
months and they're together like it was
weird we were like it was it's foggy
like more like what's our anniversary
wait so we were like hooking up but it
was like an experiment and I was like
I'm gonna talk about this like bro just
like hanging out and if every day is
good we'll just continue it and then I
think it was like official right like
probably when I started introducing to
your friends and family right which is
like around July so I guess I was
closeted for like about a year and maybe
a couple months that's so interesting I
know it's just so weird that I didn't
know you then you know I know about this
whole part of your life I know I know I
know right and now I know everything I
kind of made a concerted effort to
though to like be around people that
didn't know my previous life Oh cuz it
like I just felt like there are just too
many opinions like even some of my best
friends from college uh-huh who will
like we're obviously friends with
husband right I took like a beat from
okay husbands were still hanging out I
was like I just want to like I'm in I'm
a FLIR
yeah fighter flight I [ __ ] fly the
worst no no I like hate any sort of
conversation verbal or physical like
don't talk to me I'm getting better at
it
yeah but I'm old AF no it's nothing at
how hard like okay that was a long
tangent basically I just wanted to talk
about Cara Delevingne
but that reminded me of you but this is
a 2-fold story because she celebrated
her birthday this weekend and she'd like
a star-studded birthday with uh
obviously
Ashley Benson Suki Waterhouse Kate
Beckinsale zoe kravitz Sienna Miller and
Margot Robbie like on
Saqqara I feel like is someone who's so
famous and doesn't have any like tips
you don't even like there's nobody she
like wouldn't invite to her birthday
right Margot right Margo knows all that
I like a thingy like what kind of thing
like there was like a little bit of a
weird thing was there I feel like
because well Taylor Smith has a lot of
hot model lesbian friends which is you
know yeah I'm not that I really am not
the type of person to like out anyone I
think there's like a special place in
hell for people yeah that unlike work at
Gawker in the Delhi BTS we can steal
second did I speculate and honestly I'm
so here for it that like I don't think I
could be a bigger Taylor Swift fan but
then if she like I'm not saying that she
has like if she were to like just come
out as gay like I think I would be the
absolute biggest - Taylor Swift fan out
there Taylor we welcome you another
Taylor Taylor club oh my god you guys
could be like a throuple oh no I'm not
with those two skinny bones I know I'm
the Ice Cream Sandwich okay so she's
celebrated her birthday with all these
cool people she had several photos from
her birthday party on Instagram
according to E News quote it was my
birthday and we could go and I'm still
giggling with the amazing memories alone
though it was a mermaid party I mean I'm
assuming all the yes it was no I hate
mermaid like are you girls were like
obsessed with mermaids it's like not
that cool no it's not have you seen that
I'm iliza shlesinger
I'm not elder millennial special on
Netflix but it's her first Netflix
special no Margo and hates her Margo
like watch it she's a cloudy you have to
watch a sting I hate it I was like five
minutes a night event and all I noticed
is that she has really great ABS
but like great humour was Margo hate
watched it I hate wash she's like she
does like feminist symposium meets
comedy okay I listen I feel that like I
was I was torn I was like I think I hate
you but I also kind of love you but she
says she says stuff about mermaids in
her first special that I feel we would
all okay fine fine
I just I hate mermaids like when did
they become a staple of white girl
society I don't know cuz I don't approve
as a member of white girl Society I'm
with you I don't I do not approve but
then seeming more Cara Delevingne drama
is there was a lot of speculation I
don't know like based on what that her
and Ashley Benson were dating and like
there was never a confirmation would
love that but then this weekend in the
airport they were spotted kissing and
they were they landed in
they were kissing waiting for their bags
super cute pictures came out they both
looked super great actually looked
really happy and I guess that was like
the confirmation that the dating and she
was at her birthday party so they're
doing right like yeah yeah oh my gosh
she been thing great so I mean everyone
knew Cara was was gay yeah I don't think
anybody knew Ashley to us and like maybe
not maybe she's like me
maybe she's Cara sexual right you're
Taylor sexual Taylor sexual I'm just
attracted sexually to myself right -
master meeting and to my girlfriend
Taylor right like God forbid a million
times million times not going to a
Taylor top said yeah you're I am so
[ __ ]
hi hi I'm Kathleen right but like are
you are you dating boys I mean in my
mind it would just be first of all it is
definitely harder to be gay as a woman
because gay men have it made okay men
make Bank Ryan but like beef and like I
feel like gay gay couples have kids but
like they're so established that they're
like they're like it's like Frederick
and his yes so rich it's insane yeah
love means you know we don't make as
much money as men struggle is real seven
seven sevens always want babies which
are trans EV very oh yeah I mean it's
definitely hard to be in a female female
relationship so for that reason alone
and I love vacations and nice things of
course who doesn't I want to be on a
yacht like Jackie yeah no more sim so I
would probably date men just out of
sheer laziness oh just so you can get on
the yacht yeah honestly I still
appreciate that answer thank you I mean
I want to be a powerhouse and I want to
be like hoorah
I did it alone I run the house wins but
like I'm not a lawyer I'm not a dog
right right like I mean maybe it could
happen it's happening I can feel it you
feel it I think for both of us you guys
give me money just like show the world
that girls can do it on their own right
that's why we should all subscribe
yeah so honestly I was really I thought
those pictures of Karan Ashley in the
airport were really cute and like I
don't know I didn't see this for Ashley
Benson but now that I'm seeing it I'm
like yes let's do it
huh that's I love it she has sounds like
a weird few years after Pretty Little
Liars I did I feel like everyone in the
cast kind of found their niche
Troy Melo sorry I was about to give
birth to a baby which we on the morning
toast reported six months ago when
people said that I was fat shaming her
and I wasn't I just had really good
Intel I'm like a very reliable source
I feel like Kevin just saying that I'm
like oh really and then she waited
literally six months to announce so he
looks like an [ __ ] for six months but
I was [ __ ] right because VTO she's
like about to pop she didn't want to be
like all up in the tabloids I understand
and she's married to Patrick Adams he
was just so cute and they went to the
Royal Wedding like she has a life Shay
Mitchell is out here revolve influencer
premium content yes so like she's just
digital YouTube shake a sheen like she's
there Lucio has like had like okay
acting role she was in that CW show led
sentence that got cancelled she's in
that horrible Netflix movie doe she
looked like a so she was in the scary
movie truth-or-dare like she's like
nothing amazing but she's work and she's
making Bank right I don't really feel
like Ashley Benson has had much going on
since pretty little that's really right
I feel like she's just the type she was
dude would do what I would do but like
her new found money and fame she's like
chill yeah right and also take a girl
I'll be a lesbian yeah like I just think
I'm happy that she's she's now I feel
like she's finding her herself yeah I
don't ii mean after all this time i love
that i'm happy for her me too I know
Cara dates the best girls bad the best
car is like who - yep of the gay
community just a thought
she's our queen okay I really wanted to
do well-rounded stories for Taylor cuz
obviously we have the same celebrity bug
but I feel like there's so much more to
life these days and celebrities really
know this isn't this is you know this is
a medical story is why if you will sort
of it's from Oprah Winfrey sleep doctor
on The Daily Mail okay he's shared the
perfect step-by-step routine for optimal
rest and the one thing you should never
do before bed drink well okay all these
stories on Daily Mail are like the
medical ones are like so fake like
please like just go to sleep go to sleep
take that eggs okay the secret to sleep
is to pay attention to what you're doing
in those precious hours before bedtime
one hour before you are trying to go to
sleep you should break up your time
accordingly the sleep doctor doctor
recommends you set aside 20 minutes of
the allotted bedtime hour to finish up
your last task of the night set a
stopwatch or timer okay it's called a
phone jack it's called a
doctor said a stopwatch a timer I have a
friend call you but do something to help
you know that I wouldn't call you yeah
imagine if your friend was like can you
call me to remind me to get my sleep
yeah you need someone to call you just
to sum just so you know when twenty
minutes is up next use a 20-minute
window for hygiene so his first 20
minutes occupy yourself scrap second 20
minutes hygiene 20 minutes I need 10
seconds it's like a little deodorant
like like I don't even brush my teeth at
night me neither
rush hard in the morning yeah make up by
the way Mario was just saying you know
you're just supposed to rush your teeth
for two minutes in the morning oh really
mhm that's a long time so if I go for in
the morning I'm cool at night right
you're tired to brush my teeth at night
no I'm like once I'm in bed I'm in bed
till the morning we got it yeah unless I
have to eat something cuz that trumps
everything so for the second 20 minutes
he wants you to use that for hygiene
take other makeup wash your face brush
your teeth take a hot bath or a shower
in a dimly lit bathroom okay not
everyone's Oprah I don't have a dimmer
in my bathroom it's just on or off if
it's tilt like that's a lot
what are we babies right does this
person have a job like how do I have all
this time no this person is Oprah okay
use and then finally use the last 20
minutes to relax your body but whether
it's muscle relaxation Tai Chi
stretching or doing something for your
mind like meditation or prayer make sure
you use this time for you eighty three
percent of Australians do not set a time
I said set aside the time to unwind
every day so they can struggle with
insomnia good sleep is all about getting
good sleep hygiene this means taking to
a regular sleep routine aborting
substances like caffeine alcohol or
nicotine which interfere with health
healthy sleep and managing your stress
regular exercise can be tremendously
helpful in alleviating insomnia too as
can mindfulness practices and relaxation
therapies this doctor looks like a huge
weenie
and honestly I'm not buying what he's
selling also it's called klonopin get it
from your therapist and you're good to
go it's also just like when yours out of
shape as me you're just always tired so
like I've literally never had a problem
sleeping I mean I do have sleep anxiety
but that's what klonopins for but what
are you anxious about sleeping is the
best I think I need sleep excitement
like I can't wait to go to
scared I fight I won't be able to get to
sleep in order to wake up early in the
morning okay honestly I feel that I used
to oversleep mind there were time for my
radio show but Sirius was like starting
at 6:00 a.m.
right so I had to be up at like 4:30
when I used to you show at 7:00 a.m. I'm
like on one or two occasions I did the
whole show with you so I was there at
7:00 usually with like Rowland at the
9:30 spot yeah but at 7 o'clock I'll be
like damn it's impossible and I would
get there I'm like nervous I'll get
there like 6:30 6:45 homegirl Taylor we
get there 6:59 literally your show now
goes on today what time are you in the
chair I am actually there at like 7:30
right you need to prep yeah but before I
was like it's too early and I was like
boycotting I refuse everybody I text my
producer I'm gonna be like yeah every
day if you were late
what happened David could just like play
a stager I mean there were times I
overslept look how long my very first
show was my producer Kenny who was like
with me for like eight years he became a
co-host his very first show I slept
through the entire show and it was a
four-hour show you how did you talk
about for four hours do you repeat
yourself because no one's listening for
the fourth Scott yes because like some
was probably in for one hour and the two
well the thing is low in radio it's like
the rule is like you're always getting
new audience members and you're getting
new listeners I mean in like radio radio
like let's like say like top 40 like
that's when they like encourage them to
retell the stories in that actual show
because they believe that listeners only
pay attention for like 30 minutes
right it's who's in the car for four
hours exactly in the morning they're
like always retell stories always reset
it interesting yeah but but you can't do
that now right well I have old-school
listeners that complain like oh my god
so sick of the story right and then I
people are like oh my god no tell it
because I am a new fan from right
Claudia I'm the toes everyone should
follow Taylor by the way I'm telling you
you guys get me so many subscribers
thank you you guys and saucy oh where we
need to talk about the Stassi of it all
Margaret add that to the list of things
I want to talk to Taylor after cuz I
ballistic yes um what we're talking
about this by the state doctor is a
total hack I'm sorry Tom as well sleep
stalkers doctors not a real thing like
you don't even up to go to medical
school for it
second of all if the only people you try
and help sleep are people who are
[ __ ] billionaires and don't have to
wake up at 6:00 a.m. for like a
quote-unquote real job yes sorry like
like if you if you're able to afford a
masseuse honestly I don't have no
problem sleeping or anything if I had a
masseuse everything like all I wanted
but I'm motivated for success like you
want they god I
masseuse I want to be invited on the off
but I get seasick I want the prime plane
Oh honestly
same like totally but I would did you
ever see the Lady Gaga documentary on
Netflix yes I foot - yeah is that what
it's called yeah
sushi and by that not that I want this
but she is a masseuse with her literally
24/7 but because she has chronic pain
because she broke her hip and she's in
pain all the time and she's like
literally laying on this couch
hysterically crying she's in so much
pain and then she's think about all the
people who has the same problem with her
and like can't afford him snooze 24/7
like that was a really sad scene but it
made me not want the pain but like it
made me want the masseuse like I just
want to be at a level where like I'm
doing my big comedy show zone like in my
dressing room like my gesture now is
like literally this big with like a
couch in the dico but I want like the
big dressing room with my masseuse you
will all I want is a masseuse
I believe it I've looked vision Borden
yes okay what's on my vision board for
my number two famous plain jaw masseuse
yes
multiple homes definitely because like
honestly I'd not really like love I
don't love hotels like I always prefer
to be in like a house right but staff Oh
full-time maid obviously yeah I like how
the housekeeper come once a month and
like it's literally the best day of my
life
and I am my own housekeeper because like
I don't really want to pay for it I'm
such a cheap [ __ ] made you like and by
the way I say all this but I even I
think if I ever make it big like I still
won't spend money I know I'm so [ __ ]
four-goal me too what's the most frugal
thing you do well I I used to have a
cleaning lady once a month and now I
can't even because it's like I don't
like people in my space that I don't
know and trust then I have to like be
their baby's watching and then I'm like
she's doing it wrong so I'm like you
know what I assumed myself so I clean my
own apartment and it's him asked me how
many times my girlfriend Taylor had to
clean the toilet can you clean the
toilet yeah like how like you wipe down
the cou like scrub the inside a lot of
gagging yeah it's so disgusting well by
the way you don't even live with the boy
I can't it's so much more disgusting
there's so many more like hairs well not
even that you wouldn't live the seat so
it's a whole other level of Filth it's -
oh God yeah honestly live with the boy
and clean the toilet and you'll become a
lesbian in two seconds is that what
happened to you
where did you live when you were married
oh my god mansion mansion this guy stop
where I Becca oh no and I had run from
fredrik eklund from
I would say at Lund island from a
million are listening and he said to me
darling how would used to live before
you divorced and I was like I used to
live I came it was 260 West Street that
was the apartments that like a rich
building yes and he was like oh my god
did you read your sad divorce and I was
like no and he was like oh does your
husband still up there I don't know do
you don't ever talk to him right no no
not anymore we tried to be like amicable
but right so we're it's so hard it is
and you're out here like talking about
him on every show like obviously yeah
he's so hates me yeah I think he's like
medium hates me but his family hates me
yeah oh my god I can't even imagine like
being divorced you don't I mean it's
crazy because at one point in time like
that was your life it was me and like
you really did love him I really really
did love so beautiful at your wedding I
know I'm never good again visca will no
world that was a whole new level like I
was like thank God I capture this moment
I will never be this pretty good in my
life now I I can't get rid of the
pictures where did you know you can
because I love solar shots
not really you just Photoshop Taylor it
I'm just gonna put Taylor's face on was
Ben's head wait where did you get
married
well first date out of the handle we're
rich I love you okay this sleep doctor
it's a total crock and honestly it in
some world I am asleep doctor as well
yeah I know how to sleep yeah everything
help other people sleep first of all you
just gotta start by eating a lot because
then you're just like Jenny like out of
breath all the time and then when you
get into the bed you can't be anything
but tired you know anyway anyway that is
the key to success yes this doctor is a
sham this next story I'm really excited
about because it is something that I
thought for a while and I have all these
like conspiracy theories and
speculations about what actually goes on
in real Hollywood and I never get to
like see if they come to it like this is
totally true and I believe this 100%
Margo and you coughing you better stop
maybe people listening on the podcast
I'm sorry I have water Marga was to walk
out that's fine walk behind the camera I
can't walk out
take your microphone off and that's my
voice keeps cracking get it out now
everyone I felt like it's hurt get it
out
sickos I'm sorry for people listening on
the podcast sorry
so it's breaking up I'm like
and a Onix no girl you don't want to
keep going I'll never stop okay you good
I'm good okay
I'm I know slavers must hate you I have
a cough button do you yeah we need that
here I know okay this is the story I was
referring to page six
Angela Gillian Jolie quotes hates all
the attention Amal Clooney is getting
and this makes so much sense whether you
go Angelina Jolie is insanely jealous of
Amal Clooney friends said because quote
she believes Amal has stolen her
identity as the world's most prominent
glamorous humanitarian fair their death
which Angela no never she was always
crazy one source tells page six Angelina
hates all the attention that Amal is
getting she's beautiful she's smart
she's stylish she has a beautiful family
and she's doing important human rights
work
yeah Jolie is also fuming the former
close friends George Clooney animal have
publicly taken her soon-to-be ex-husband
Brad Pitt side in their increasingly
messy divorce while the fallout from
their divorce battle is making Julia
appear crazy and manipulative
I mean look like we finally see the
curtain drop the source adds Angelina
lives in such a bubble
she believes that a mouths doing a
single body female on her and Angie
can't understand why she herself has
become so unpopular with Hollywood you
thought but the truth is Amal isn't
concerned at all with Angelina she is
fully focused on her family and her work
that's like the most mean thing you
could say like honestly like Angelina's
are losing sleep over I'm all and I'm
all doesn't even think about Angelina
well Jolie has six children runs two
charitable foundations two jolie-pitt
Foundation and the Maddox jolie-pitt
Foundation good I get it yeah they do
good stuff
she holds a role as a UN Special Envoy
Amma's and mother to one year-old twins
Ellen Alexander and his esteemed human
rights lawyer here's the thing I mean
there's not even a competition in my
eyes like just with my personality I'm
pointed so much more rather hang out
with them all than I would enter Li not
yes
and there's definitely I don't like to
pit women against each other but if I'm
going to it's gonna be these two because
I've been dying to talk about this
here's the thing Angelina Jolie yes she
was like a humanitarian un global
ambassador like taking all of her kids
to Africa while also being like a famous
actress in like in the depravity of
Hollywood like I'm sorry yeah my liver
like set out to be famous do you know
what I mean I mean if she did she hides
it very well right like she amalga like
well known because of her humanitarian
work which was so much more impressive
than like a celebrity who got famous off
of like making out with her brother
on a red carpet and also like wearing
blood vials around her neck with Billy
Bob before right brahim she stole from
who an actress who I'm totally blanking
on right now but really like no but like
that to me what I'm also to some
impressive then like a celebrity
leveraging their platform and their and
their finances to like do good work
which is still really good but like you
can't even begin to compare em all to
Angelina Angelina stuff was like all
about like PR and propaganda and was
like she was like trying to recoup her
bad girl image right I didn't know that
I felt like yes it's great
helping the world is wonderful no matter
what your motivation I just felt like
her motivation was inside the pure azzam
all right and like let's not forget
Angelina Jolie's dad is Jon Voight who
plays Nicolas Cage his dad in national
treasure yeah I'm sure he's in other
stuff but I only know him from national
treasure and so it she grew up in
Hollywood she's ever like a spoiled brat
she was like a bad girl she had learned
making out her brother like sick like
she's so deeply problematic on so many
levels but like then she got her [ __ ]
together and she was the most beautiful
woman in the world and when she got the
most handsome man in the world and they
were mr. mrs. Smith is the smoothie
stall okay I don't agree with that he
also got stole so they're both bad yeah
no no but like I mean how could you
resist her no not even that like
Jennifer Aniston seems like a [ __ ]
nightmare to be married to sorry I'm
saying it okay I I have a good good like
I'm at an easy time separating Jennifer
Aniston and Rachel Green because they
love friends and love Rachel Green but
honestly Jennifer Aniston especially
like modern-day Jennifer Aniston I'm so
not here for like I'm just I don't like
her I'm sorry
I'm with you I know it's an unpopular
thing to say is it like she's she's like
what America's Sweetheart I was team
Jennifer just by default of not liking
Angie but I really like Jennifer that
much either
that's so interesting I just
automatically took Brad Pitt side cuz
he's just like he is married sweetheart
Brad Pitt yeah yeah yeah wherever he
goes he left Jen I was team Brad he left
Angie I'm team Brad he's a one-man show
you're right I'm actually team Brad
who's gonna I was just gonna say who do
you think is like perfect for him god
this is hard maybe Jennifer Lawrence you
know what she's really pissing me off
I'm with you I'm such a fan and I love
her me too
silver linings playbook is so good but
like these these this artistic side of
her and these like dark men she's
meeting Darren Aronofsky no but ultimate
I say that right yes it's very important
to note her silence on the me tube
movement she okay she got her start in
only Weinstein Company movies like she
her and YB YB Harvey are tight as hell
she has not said one thing about it even
if she came out she was like I don't
want to make a statement because this
person was good to me right for everyone
that saw a bad side I never saw that so
from my experience you know so that's
why I'm not more like Matt or maybe good
on her like yes I knew what it took to
get into Hollywood intimidate to do okay
I didn't want a specially if he said
that right now saying anything is like
Stosh a day and now she said right when
all of it was happening she was like I'm
taking a two-year break from acting
maybe because like she'd want anyone to
like put the pieces together about her
and Harvey I'm saying I think her and
Harvey hope to have yes no hope that
makes it sound like consensual okay
right you know and you never know with
that psychopath oh god who wants first
of all when I get naked for the shower I
don't want to even see myself oh I'm
actually imagine parading around like
look at this no and he's only recently
like thin like forever he was literally
at 400 pounds disgusting
I wish I was not but did you see those
pictures of him walking into court like
with those biographies no when he went
to turn himself in he walked in with
like four or five by like books like
text books people like what are they
they were like the biographies of great
men Oh does he think that's him I just
understood men he must have some sort of
personality disorder there's no way you
can do what you did what he did and be
like I mean and so be stable no he's
he's wrong it is it's like maybe it's
wrong in the head but it's also that's
really what happens to you when you get
so powerful and she's so rich really dog
there's got to be people who don't go
down that rabbit hole here's the thing I
I like to think that but then I look at
take a look at myself and I have like a
very very small amount of power just cuz
I'd like a big Instagram foam and think
you have a pretty medium amount of how
thank you you're welcome
but like you know in the world that we
live in like the discussing one that we
had like Instagram followers mean
something yes again I take full
advantage of that and I do think I
abused my power quite a bit so like I
can't say that like if I ever got super
rich of famous like I wouldn't abuse it
Morden I mean I'm abusing it right now
how I don't know I just am I'm always
like wielding it like a weapon like over
people you know like if you make me mad
I'm not gonna yeah exactly
I won't tag you well actually I mean I
have less power than you I'm smarter
it's still a power yeah but I definitely
but listen it's not wielding power to
withhold like your Instagram all right I
actually just had a fight about
Instagram with somebody and I referenced
you and Stassi okay and I said listen I
don't owe you my instagram my instagram
is mine it's my business I'm cultivating
it it's very delicate for me I said it's
very well-thought-out slash also full of
my insecurities right like I'm not think
about anybody else on it's remote add to
the list of things I want to talk to
Taylor about Instagram stories yes when
I Instagram okay I'm like thinking about
me me me me me me me in the audience but
like also like it secured me me me me me
so this is Sansa this one because this
this person was saying you need to tag
me more and I was like you are barking
up the wrong tree for a thousand
different to tell me who it is after oh
no I don't think you know but anyway so
it won't be as delicious delicious but I
still won I remember I said listen I
have friends I get it like ratio-wise
you like you see my numbers and you're
like you could help my numbers right but
like I have Claudia and Stassi and I've
never once said to them will you post or
what you've never I'm like when they do
it it's a gift appeared in story do
expectation so like yeah that's what I
like I think that's not wielding power I
think that that's just you protecting
your business in your brand it is but
there's also like a special place in
hell for people who specifically don't
do it like I if you didn't tag me in the
photo I just know it's cause honestly
you're not that savvy on that internet
dirt I'm like you're a little bit of a
Grimm I wanna come set I when you think
like oh she's trying to a boxing person
I was like it don't take it personally
yes so the people who like take it but
there are people who like are psychotic
about it and I can't do it intentionally
then it's like almost mean yes so it's a
that's true there's definitely a lot of
Mean Girl Shaddai yes yes on the
incident going on the internet yeah
totally that's a really ugly picture of
you and you're like you that's not even
the best picture of you right so so I
feel two ways about that because every
time I post a picture and like it's me
and Ben he goes dude you even look at me
and I'm like no and I look at him in
like his eyes are closed like whatever
I'm so self-involved I'm not looking at
any other person in a photo wait but
it's because it's the best picture of
you right what if somebody posts a
picture that's me
picture of them and a terrible picture
maybe it was the best picture they got
you know you never know what if I knew
that they had many more really nice
pictures but how do you know that cuz I
just know okay so Angelina's jealous of
them all honestly like this makes me so
much happy I just feel like at one point
in time Angelina Jolie had nothing in
the world to worry about like him what
is that like like she was so rich she
was on good terms with her dad yeah
married to the hottest man in the world
was saving lives had seven kids like it
both adopted and natural born like I
just really at one point in time she had
the perfect life and she had absolutely
nothing to worry about and I can't
really imagine what that's like she
self-destructed right and now it's like
she has so much to worry about and I'm
like welcome join join the club yeah
right she's finally I'm half human
yeah I'm happy for the humanization that
is happening and please just don't
compare yourself to around Clooney like
you were just not even on the same like
Amal Clooney has potential to be the
first lady like literally and I would be
okay with it
Meech look very acceptable yeah she
should just give up that fight that's a
losing battle yeah like she was at the
Royal Wedding and George Clooney just
sold whatever it's called for a billion
dollars yeah it's so good George
Clooney's richer than Brad Pitt right I
would say yeah cuz in the movie world's
Brad Pitt's richer because he's it is in
more he produces more it has had bigger
hits but the billion dollars that but I
hate to split the billion dollars with
three people so far it's 330 know what
I'm I'm just saying a plane is 30 mil
that's like a huge chunk of 330 God
really yeah just like wait no they are
in the lair
well you said pizzas Network they're
very similar Brad Pitt is 240ml and
George Clooney's 300 mil okay they're in
the same realm okay but I never trust
networks one cuz the internet the
celebritynetworth.com is fake they said
my net worth is 275 grand like lol I
wished and now worth isn't like how much
money you have in the bank like that's
what I wanted Network net worth is the
value of all the things you own so like
your car's your businesses your homes
anything you've invested in like your
vent investments like so well it's
definitely a good depiction of how rich
you are like you could have a lot of
money in the bank or just not be like if
I let see had a lot of money in the bank
I rent my apartment I don't have a car I
don't invest in businesses all right you
would never know that I have a lot of
money in the bank I don't net worth
doesn't
money in the bank no that's why it's
like when you look up the housewives
it's so fake because like it could be so
house porn right and like they all I
guess they have like nice nice cars and
stuff but like that's not a real
depiction of money also you buy a new
car driving off the law and like just
drops
oh I'm so [ __ ] everyone leases their
card it's something like $20 a month on
a car I just found that out was like I
don't drive I never drove I never had a
car like and I make my license yes
actually I don't have an ami cuz I lost
it but I do have it like in the system
if I were to get arrested they would say
I'm a licensed driver okay I got
arrested I me pulled over No and I'm a
good driver
but that's it wait yes what I never knew
that like people like leased cars I
didn't know there was a thing so I'm
like how do all these people spend like
30 grand on a car like my gym everyone's
rich and then Ben was like no honey like
everyone pays $10 a month further yeah
okay I could maybe afford a street
parking it I know
let me parking range from over I really
want a car just because I feel like it'd
be good for my life and like when I have
kids I'm telling I like drive them to
school and [ __ ] but the parking I can't
that's why I don't have a car and I
genuinely can't park I genuinely can't
afford the parking available parking
nowhere else and I can't like oh you
know well luckily each one of these when
you hold the back senior oh you can't
parallel park no it's impossible
no no it's no it's not but the car there
of course I'd do it for you now
I know me too how much is that per month
just seven million dollars okay okay now
we have some business okay
financial news it's actually really
interesting we on the show love when
companies like merger companies buy
other companies because it gives us hope
like maybe you know
Turner like ten Warner will buy the
choice do you know like it doesn't gives
us in inspires okay it's doing it and
it's the thing that actually really does
happen right Casey nice at getting
ninety million dollars from CNN and then
getting fired like are you kidding me
ready ready
PepsiCo which by the way I'm endlessly
impressed with Pepsi as a company even I
think more so than coca-cola I prefer to
drink coca-cola meet-u meet-u but I'm
saying is it PepsiCo turn them at their
portfolio
they're like Disney frito-lay yes taco
bell/pizza hut I didn't know it ain't
Margo Google what companies PepsiCo owns
your gonna be a blown away you think
it's Pepsi like Pepsi sprite like
whatever but no yeah all the shitty
drink yeah yeah fast food like still
meant like businesses like it's crazy
Meli's gatorade Tropicana Doritos brisk
brisk what else whatever like club like
fast food chains oh fast food chain
because I think they own Taco Bell and
Pizza Hut that's like when you go to a
fast restaurant and you're like why do
you only have Pepsi right - Hut Taco
Bell KFC Long John Silver's steam and a
and W Western restaurant I'm not that
but see so L is enough enough for me to
worship them forever you wanna hear
something crazy
I love - I've never had talked about can
we go well I don't eat meat
because we're kosher Oh God and I've had
the chip say guac from guac from talk
about honest delicious but yeah I know
can't you get it like you don't eat meat
no and I don't
I eat only clothes for me oh right so we
get as well there's a kosher McDonald's
and it's the same thing but just for
pushing me right and it's so good that
would talk about that's that makes me
that breaks my heart I know but I don't
really like that something even if I did
eat the meat I don't let you pull it
either I don't like like Mexico
discussing but / like if I'm hammered
I'll eat it right
but at stassi's birthday Katie ordered
like Late Late Late Night talk--i Bell
and I poured it and I hid in my room and
I eat it for breakfast the next day what
do what do you get like a taco I just
like go straight up
it says no I'm gonna feel like I'm like
such a lesbian but that's like it of the
bed yeah and what are you getting it
it's just like soft shell of course
sweet eyes curvy hips I'm gonna give up
I'm gonna kill her um like some hot
sauce in there a little cheese little
lettuce you know like they like do it up
and talk it's like the soft beef taco
supreme mm-hmm I love it okay what
speaking about me chocolates mean
PepsiCo has bought SodaStream
for three billion dollars what's
SodaStream whoops that machine it's like
so you don't have to buy Seltzer in your
own and a bubble - yeah and now then you
can also make like Thai code you can
make literally anything so honestly
PepsiCo buying it is genius Wow because
you could make the seltzer and but if
you before you make this else you put
the powder in and you can make it like
fruit punch like you can make whatever
you carbonated drink you want you
like a k-cup almost yeah it's really
smart Wow so Indra Nooyi who is the
female CEO of PepsiCo another reason to
love pepperoni at the chief executive
and officer announced Monday that Pepsi
will be buying SodaStream one of the top
world's top sparkling water brands
PepsiCo will take over the Israeli
company known for its DIY Seltzer makers
in a deal worth three billion dollars
holy crap they must be so excited I know
Nooyi the CEO said this month that
she'll step down in October after more
than a decade as a CEO she has steered
Pepsi toward healthier offering saying
it's important for the company's future
because of consumers increasing
attention to health
she's definitely right about that
SodaStream products marked as healthy
alternative to sugary sodas fit Pepsi's
goals of making more nutritious while
limiting our environmental footprint
because there's no bottles you reuse the
same bottle every time right um plastic
together we can advance our shared
vision of a healthier more sustainable
planet so it's too bold it's healthier
for the planet and it's healthier for
you Wow
I got cheaper it's cheaper I have a
SodaStream because when me and Ben moved
in he like went to bed and asked me on
till I get shampoo and he like came back
with a SodaStream it was like one of the
weirdest things ever and I did use it
for a while it does work for sure I just
like never have like water in my house
to like make that and I know what I just
have because if I'm making this like
fancy seltzer I'm gonna use bottled
water what kind
put your favorite Poland Spring don't
mess with perfection I do love but I'm
also don't say smart water okay I think
use a Fiji there's a special candy house
you like yeah I'm not like people like
it's people who like choose to buy it
but why are you a sociopath you know I
know it takes a little much SmartWater
is good because they have the sport cap
you got it yeah
but I've never tried any of the
SodaStream like flavors like I just like
pop it in and make cell tower I want to
know if when you use like the Diet Pepsi
well it'll be Diet Pepsi not Diet Coke
do you use like that but they call it
diet cola problem with that actually
right and I know what it tastes like
are there anyone in the comments who has
used it as a testimonial and let me know
what you think of like you can sprite I
think you can make diet cola or like
orange soda I don't know I've never done
any of that cuz like it seems
unnecessary and like that's how to get
you like that's why it's a three billion
dollar company cuz not only do you have
to buy the Machine you have to keep
buying like the cake that's my Keurig
makes so much you have to keep
replenishing yeah dollars is so much
like how does Pepsi just have like
billion dollars like chili even though
they are like the biggest company in the
world like how much money do they have
in the bank that they could just like
write a check for 3 billion I tried
looking it up yeah and it's just like a
stock number that I don't so that would
be a good time to invest in PepsiCo yeah
Ben has talking probably slightly too
late
yeah then gets like literally a check
once a month for literally 10 cents
because he has like one share of Pepsi
oh one day
that's share then it comes in the mail
like super old [ __ ] I always forget oh
my name is this PepsiCo man I'm like oh
you have Venice it's like old school
like that it I think his parents bought
for him like years ago illusion yeah
right like that's a really smart thing
to do I feel we're saying that the
flavors are disgusting oh people are
saying the flavors are just got staying
interesting but that's the key in order
to be rich you need to not only invent a
product but invent a product that
requires additional maintenance Keurig
like yeah you can buy the machine for
twenty dollars be so glad I get those
stupid [ __ ] hiccups every time you
run out yeah like ShamWow like buy one
you're done right what the [ __ ] but I
guess I love a Jewish Shark Tank
ah yeah did you watch the season I don't
actually I don't think I have it's on
Amazon by the way you should watch a
tomato because Bethany is a guest shark
twice and she is confirmed coming back
on the next season why I didn't watch
oh right not a fan okay so we went in
tomorrow we're going in tomorrow
tomorrow where we go in we go in on yeah
Bethany home because she's like kind of
team Carol I think I definitely made an
important change you did you you open my
eyes and I do I hate Bethany less than I
I respect the high you of a personal
expect I did back there she was a dick
and I was like a fan and then I was like
I can't believe each of your fans like
this right like she went out of her way
they wrote and honestly it's way easier
to be nice and it is to be rude so much
easier but sometimes being nice like
people take advantage of you so like
maybe not I had like 10 minutes with her
in a studio like in series was like
moving her around she could have like it
sucked it up for 10 minutes and when
you're that rich just like stop
complaining game right honestly if I was
just like 100 million dollars richer not
honestly is it bad that I don't anything
a hundred million dollars would cover
what I needed to cover no I'm with you
because if the plane is 30 and then I'm
only left with 16 and okay let's say you
get me let's play this game we had a
hundred million dollars yeah
tomorrow what do you do so with it I
immediately buy the apartment that 11
right now oh you read them to a bigger
and better one well I will but I just
love love love it and it always be like
a pet of Tierra so if we decide
leave the apartment and be just like the
perfect place should just like Carrie
Bradshaw she always keeps apartment
exactly so I would keep this apartment
because like I love love love it and
it's like super affordable yeah I mean
if I'm a millionaire I would probably
buy like another bigger well I would
think of buying a bigger stick or
apartment for what I needed to but that
would definitely get a place in LA not
nothing like a huge huge huge just want
bigger house definitely how's the body
yard at need a pool Amelie you don't
want to get a dog yeah no are you gonna
drop or sell I do that or did I make
that up I don't have a cat okay good out
here you rude sorry I didn't sorry Kathy
I didn't you protect that stereotype I
thank you cats um no I'm just uh yeah I
can okay so how much was your apartment
in New York cost if you were to buy it
it wouldn't be that much would be like
under a million okay so that's doesn't
happen that's like how much are you
spending on your LA house yes like I
mean one time I saw the Olsen twins sell
their place for like two male and I'm
like you can you can get an Olsen twin
place where two males I would you like
it I do like I'm very low I'm like low
rich two to three then I'm we gonna
bottom out and Hampton yeah of course
but that's not five no I would do like
ten six okay and then I would buy my mom
and dad's house or Austin because they
[ __ ] love it and they could live
there but it's mine right and you can
pick them anytime you wanted Cody you
only spent like ten million dollars and
that's just homes and then and then
airplanes cuz I gotta get if I'm in each
of all funny right so that's 35 in your
45 plus an extra five million for
hangars fees for the next couple years I
don't be like crazy crazy you know what
I would like to Thailand I want to be
the kind of rich person who takes like a
ton of money and just like puts it into
like really safe like on bond yep not
high risk yep like whatever
pep talks and just live off the dividend
okay so that's always what Ben says and
it's so true so if I were to get one
hundred million dollars I would probably
put 20 million of it in a savings
account that earns interest and like
right now my savings account earns
interest but like there's a hunter
[ __ ] in there so I get literally ten
cents every month but one percent
interest on 20 million dollars every
month that's fun that's AH like oh sorry
I'm putting yet no I'm 20 I'm putting 20
it is it - I'm so bad at this man what I
don't know five hundred thousand dollars
a month I don't know if one person I
don't know if one percent interest is
the real number it might be like point
oh wow okay so let's say it's even let's
say it's
say it's to $200,000 long right that's
perfect who could not live off that I
could I certainly my 20 mil is going in
the bank with the rest of the eight
emails 30 if it is gonna buy the plane
and then an extra five for the hangar
fees so that's 55 already 85 with my
obit 20 30 35 55 and a 45 left 10 mil on
Holmes cuz I'm I I'm I'm waiting to get
into this building co-op board and I'm
not gonna end up renting that apartment
I'm just gonna buy apartment on the top
floor then have a views of the park yeah
my apartment is view Park but what does
the building do that probably cost me
like 10 or 11 mil yeah
how's the Hamptons for sure for sure 24
yeah I don't need to be that crazy and
Hamptons like usually the pool I don't
to be on the water I want to take my my
Hamptons real estate down yeah I want to
buy a house and I would buy a house in
Turks and Caicos and that's where I'd
really put like my money but the house
that we say that yeah that house was
sick yeah and it's like a rentable house
but I would like me to clean it cuz like
people have stayed there including us
and I know how poor let me drink to that
okay oh there's another story I'm at
SodaStream we really took that on a
tangent I know me and Jackie are crazy
with our tangents it's ready 11 2001
ever we're going late today yeah final
story of the day and we have some
pictures to attach to make sure you're
tuning in Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas
had a second engagement party last night
and it was lame honestly I don't care
about that one I care about the one in
India of that those are the pictures
were surfacing Nick Jonas flew to India
had a traditional I want pronounced
really sorry correctly Roka ceremony
which is a traditional engagement
ceremony in India in Mumbai and then
they had an another engagement party
last night in LA which was like thirsty
and like Saudi but right the meaningful
one was in in Mumbai and I just can't
therefore I tell you your thoughts there
their fake relationship why are they
like clearly it's fake because they're
protesting so much who has to I mean I
guess culturally yes have the one move I
mm-hmm oh well actually I guess like I
can justified then you would have one
with your friend right cuz they're gonna
be like hey come to India right but if
you can't make it right they did like a
low-key one and then like I meaningful
over to where the [ __ ] did they come
from
no this whole thing how do they meet he
is the most boring person I've ever
my entire why don't you interview him
why not serious I interviewed him but
when he was out of Jonas Brothers and he
was like I'm an artist right solo and he
was like so I can't even say too cool
for school cuz cool was nothing a part
of it right it was just like you are so
thank God boy you can sing because you
were cute yes yes hey me little too some
can go on to say he's not my type much
Mario when you were a kid because I'm a
LESBIAN when you were a kid though and
you love the Joyce brothers meet you
and you would love the Jonas Brothers
who was like your brother I mean I don't
know I I feel like I was more like in
college when they were like big big so I
guess like tall Jonas that was with
Camilla Belle yeah Jo meet you I love
him okay here are my thoughts because
when I saw these pictures it's like this
literally nobody can tell me any
differently if this relationship is a
farce it is a PR stunt
it's and we-we'd blinds so online like
that's everyone says like there's no
doubting that this is the fakest [ __ ]
relationship out there first of all
they've known each other for two months
second of all they're just so not
compatible like in any way look I don't
see them getting along she is like an
intellect
she's like a serious actress like she
made the transition from Bollywood to
Hollywood which is really hard she was
invited to the royal wedding like she is
so here yes and he is like a [ __ ]
Jonas Brother with four front teeth like
I'm sorry I just don't see it like and
people are saying people on Instagram by
commenting like I don't understand why I
can't just be happy for that like I can
but they're trying to use the public as
a toy but why who's benefiting this is
why I actually believe but their star is
rising I so we've never spoken about
Nick Jonas so much and we've never
spoken about Priyanka so much cher I
know that scooter problems accused of
doing that with Peter now with Peter
area after after Justin and Bailey yes
they got together and I actually don't
think that scooter operates like that
but I do think whoever is in charge of
them did yep me too
yep here's the thing this is just the
only thing I'm a little confused about
this is like kind of an extreme lengths
to go to for a fake relationships like
involved like her like her Indian family
and like them make everyone travel to
Mumbai like this is where I'm like well
this is taking it a little far and I've
always said like literally it's real no
I've always said Priyanka and it could
literally have an
hundred year marriage with millions of
grandkids and I can live a happy life
together and like move out to the
country and like not be famous anymore
and I still wouldn't believe it I I'm
with you and I just I don't know accept
this but this part doesn't make sense
and this is also how I feel about Karlie
Kloss and Josh Kushner because there are
serious rumors you know she's engaged
Karlie Kloss
yes I'm picturing him he's cute he's
Jared Kushner's brother Jared Kushner is
married to Ivanka aha so there have been
rumors forever that she is lesbian and
that he is gay and that this is like a
beard relationship love right or makes
you and naps and what they say about
Carly and Taylor Swift I'm deep in this
telescoped lesbian conspiracy there
because I wanted to be true so bad but
hm I know but so honestly made a lot of
sense cuz she is very like socialite he
comes from like a very prestigious
family he's like a big tech entrepreneur
like they were the perfect bearded
couple for each other you think but now
but now them getting engaged Carly and
Josh just like taking it a little too
far well if it's fake so you could have
just been boyfriend/girlfriend for like
a couple more years
same as Niki Priyanka they could have
dated for two years like this is so long
I mean they're about two months like
this is a very serious step to take in a
fake relationship so now I'm confused
now here okay so here's where I am now
so like in them like when I was getting
a divorce or whatever like obviously I
wanted out get away from me and like
them are dating Taylor so I would love
so in love so in love like now like I
mean still love a Taylor but it's like
oh my god can you imagine if I just like
had like I don't know like wasn't I are
separated I stir me up with Taylor and
I'm like hey was it right want to talk
about like like let's make a deal like I
will be your wife right she will be like
our best vanilla that uh-huh
we were in relationship you can date
whoever you want so get the credit card
yeah yes yes and we can how like have
the kids but Taylor will have them but
we can use like my embryo would Taylor
be down for that or she has so much
integrity
way too much integrity yes she's a
daughter however do you have done me no
I'm so dude that sounds awesome
I know right I mean I feel like so what
he had been down I don't know I don't
think so I don't think no well maybe
because I nobody would let him say what
he does I think he feels like Dani is
exhausting right you know so if you
found out like like out you sawn into
him like he got engaged I think would
freak me out right I do but then I would
have to I really
be happy for him he can hate me but I
don't hate him doesn't you think hmm I
think no I think he understands exactly
why we're not together yeah and I think
he I think he hates that I talk so much
yeah but I think that he like definitely
knows that it's not just an issue and
Emily's right like you didn't break up
with him because you were a lesbian you
found that asteroid you book on him
because it's family be so mean to you
yeah they hated me it was I tried every
angle to change it the only way we're
gonna work as if I shut up for the rest
of my life and just did whatever he told
me to do that's not my personal right
and so I was just gonna be totally miss
and I know he's gonna like trickle down
to our kids we're like their kids are
gonna pass her on my kids I'm like it's
gonna be all [ __ ] up that's a good
call yeah there's family dynamics are
really hard to break and they're like
intergenerational yeah and also like I
was like I'm not a victim and I like I
don't get picked on like I'm great like
you know a nice trolley upended woman
you are lost and I felt like we were the
ones that were like punching bags I'm
like you I don't be the punching bag
couple Oh totally we don't want to be
that lets me better and so I like
encouraged him to like push back Rick
it's not his personality right okay well
you know let you give your all I can't
marry for I was married for for for like
four five I would say five years by the
time we got divorced because we got
married in July when our divorce is
final in July yes great that's a period
of your life that good college try
exactly yes okay now I don't list of
things I want to talk to you about
because those were the five stories I
hope you guys feel more well-rounded you
know or informed yeah it's always good
to start your day with a big heaping
pile of information the first thing I
want to talk to you about is younger
okay because if you guys don't know
Taylor a host the younger official TV
land after show yes thank you second
year in a row wait so it was an after
show it's confusing
it wasn't have to show now it's a
pre-show oh yes that's even better get
to go home early
no kidding so a younger it's called
getting younger same name both both ears
and then now instead of the after show
what we do is we do an after-show
podcast Oh younger uncovered I wouldn't
know that it's really good and we get
like all the cast mates come in
one-on-one interviews it's really good
it's really really good okay so I did
the show last year when it was the
after-show that's why I still thought
that was it I'm so sorry no no and it
was so fun except that the studio didn't
have air conditioning and we were dying
so we're in a studio that is sick I
don't know if they're open strings that
much better but it's like it's an square
it's so great
and actually we're gonna be doing an
after show for the season finale right
so it's gonna be good so because it's a
cheap it's official TV land production
you get the host cast I get the whole
guy so you've met everyone is there
anyone you haven't met nope and tell me
about Charles what's his real name
Pierre human he is exactly like his
character will you give him a message
for me yes I will sex that's my message
okay well actually I meant I'm doing a
podcast with him I think when next week
we're gonna come or maybe yeah I mean
tend to be the sound engineer I don't
know if he's gonna be in studio
oh look on the phone you mean would you
want to say come listen to him now I
could watch the show I could listen to
him there
I could listen is about like you know if
he's if he's in I'll be like see coming
on the show at the pre-show ever again
this season I don't think so
he came on I know he's been on the
podcast one said he loved it so she
wanted to come back I know he loved you
some Lanka embrace him like a hug what
is it so actually so so the the good
thing is like the podcast was really
good too with getting with the pre-show
getting younger because like cameras are
scary yes and like people especially
when you're loved
yes and also like a person that cares a
lot of an image yeah like it can be like
and also like super famous like let's
say Hillary definitely like if she's
uncomfortable in her outfit it's gonna
totally throw her do you know what I
completely and so with the podcast
there's like no soul a basher and so I
felt like they got to come in they were
just like chilling they're like this is
cool and a lot of them hadn't done
podcast before right it's a new medium
and so when Peter came in I was like hi
Peter Taylor and he was like okay he
like hit my hand when he's like get over
here and he gave me a hug he's like I
know who you are does he do the show
last year yeah he totally knows but I
was like but they could forget me though
right and he's my verse for Hargitay
he's a full life yeah she ever come no I
know that would be epic like imagine but
he does talk about her what is he said
he he like doors her so much and they
also definitely watch like their shows
together yeah and we like always ask
them about like is she rooting for you
know like you and Liza right or Josh who
are you rooting for
I am so team Josh it's not yes here's
the thing I don't just agree with you
because I was just learning about this
with my friends last night cuz my
friends just started watching it they're
like in the middle and they're like we
left Charles [ __ ] I'm like save like
I I love Charles
me honestly at this point I'm so fed up
with Liza she's so irrational she's
always making poor decisions and like
you know it you and Josh are perfect for
each other because you're gallivanting
around Brooklyn like a [ __ ] 25 year
old when you're a 40 year old mom and
you still like are not getting serious
like great Josh is perfect for you
Charles need a woman like me a serious
woman first of all his brownstone is
everything that's reason enough alone to
marry an bowtie but for me I like Josh
okay I'm gonna get wait I can't believe
you like Josh I love Josh because it
represents that you can do whatever you
want life no matter what part or stage
of life you're in so you're being
emotional and B no I'd like I feel like
Josh and Liza represent Taylor and
Taylor okay but whereas like I feel like
Charles and lives it represents like
like checking the boxes okay which is
not bad no but also you can't deny the
fact like that Charles is so hot and
it's so much in common with the
literature what the hell do Josh and
Charles have in common I know but even
Hilary Duff's it during our podcast she
was like what are they gonna do sit
around and talk about books all day boy
totally but that's what they like so
what she need to know Josh like keeps
her young and different and it's just
that I can't believe that you are team
Josh that is so weeny
I'm just projecting my own life onto it
that's fair but honestly like everyone
the world's team Charles and Darren
Criss always get not Darren Criss Darren
star Darrell have you met him yes I feel
like he's awesome he's wonderful he's
like a real person is to come in the
pre-show um he he's the creator of the
show he sells the creator of section
that's not yet the season but he may or
may not be coming on for one of the last
two dying what is he like I feel like
he's so cool so he is like so famous he
is so famous he acts like he does not
know that he is like shy so we were on
the red carpet together during the first
so season four premiere so my first
season of getting younger and they made
me like take a picture of the cast which
was like so embarrassing cuz I'm like I
don't know these people and bright no me
either like who the [ __ ] is this growing
snuggly jacket but then I was like never
lay off so Darren was like smack down
the middle because he's the king and he
the second the picture was done like
they all kept going down and like doing
it like individuals like together and
Darren and I could not have [ __ ] run
faster off that red carpet like we were
so uncomfortable right and then I was
like hey
today's speech because I just an
interview with the whole cast serious
and he's look to me he was like um like
how we met that was like oh don't worry
and I was like um I knew you I
interviewed you yesterday it's serious
I'm Taylor and he went like this you
look so different and then he me oh my
god that was so rude and I was like no I
get it all the time
I'm the radio you know a monster on the
radio and I have like a glamazon team
now so like no offense and by the way
you use for your glamazon team Priscilla
and Julius who are does all the
housewives yeah I met them through Stasi
right they do all Brava you're amazed no
Priscilla such so good at makeup you
look so good on getting on they're so
good right tell me about the intra cast
relationships like who's friendly was
not nice I think I really can't say
anyone's not nice I mean and they all
get along so well which seems like such
[ __ ] right but it's really not like
well I know that Debbie and Darren are
super tight Debbie made oh my god I am
obsessed I can imagine that in real life
she's probably the most exciting to me
she's so cool she is so fun and like I'm
I going her character with her is you me
already
she's amazing she's very amazing but
she's super strong and has like I mean
McDonough is her best friend
what Yas Queen she also has a show on
Food Network bitching kitchen is it
current no I think it's old but I heard
her husband like have like this whole
like life together like cooking and me
traveling and yes he's fab yeah I love
her and I love that this show is like
brought her into the 21st century
because she did the most amazing post on
her Instagram about 13 reasons why did
you see it you know what so it here's
the thing I did see it but I'm really
close to Selena Gomez's mother Mandy TV
you are yep she was a huge listener of
the show back in the day wait how do I
show that and I met Selena at Sirius and
she was banging on the glass while like
they were like seriously like there's
somebody wants to meet you and I thought
I was like an execs kid so I come
downstairs Selena Gomez who I know
because as a grown woman yes i watch
Disney Channel of course AAB so she was
like came running she's like oh my god
I've never been more excited to meet
anybody in my entire life
and she said my mom successfully you are
her best friend and then her mom came
around the corner was like I'm shaking
I've like met like every celebrity in
the world and like I can't even right
now with you wait how and so then I got
really close with a pendant you Manafort
manifest a friendship like to have her
number
the mom yes so
to text forever yes so this so before
she became Selena became clean up before
she started singing and it was like all
Wizards I was like so anti Miley
carriage meet everybody
well now I love her that's not what I
hear but okay now I love her so I was
like I would always come for Miley and I
mean Selena always handled herself very
gracefully but I could tell like they
liked that I working them yep and so
then Solis are doing this music thing
and Mandy was oh and they liked it like
articles and they would like they would
like put me in articles like getting me
quote whoops they were so good to me
yeah and then when sleeve did not truly
when you're with me baby yeah I was like
she's gonna be a [ __ ] superstar and I
stood backstage at what's what's the
Gramercy small theater that Gramercy
Gramercy Theatre oh there you go yeah
with the marquee si yeah there was a
bunch of like three-year-olds on their
parents shoulders and me backstage was
Mandy and then katharine mcphee with
blond hair and like fishnet stockings on
that was why i understand that
connection whatever and i said Maddie
she's going to be a star and then she
was and then I lost touch with them ah
be like no harm no foul when you're that
famous you have to like rein it in right
and then I interview Justin Bieber and
like my whole shtick was like Justin
Bieber you stole my best friend Selena
Gomez and he was not here for it Oh God
and I almost got fired over that oh he
wouldn't take a picture with me Justin
Bieber and then I was like [ __ ] this kid
and I hated him for a bajillion years
but I'm over now cuz sorry is like my
favorite song still it's a really good
song it's the bass this is so so you
didn't agree with Debi Mazar Instagram
post about thirteen reasons why because
of Mandy because I made a show oh a bud
and Salinas and Mandy I interview Mandy
about it and she said that she it's on
taste of Taylor somewhere and she
recently and she said well maybe like a
couple months ago and she said that she
actually bought the project for Selina
like back in the day before she started
becoming like this big like pop star
because she wanted her to have like an
important role well I loved the show
first season I thought it was like an
important show and I did think it was
like a little harsh epic and it did kind
of glorify suicide but like it's TV and
that's short TV glorify stuff right but
I'd like without even meaning to right
right I and people were up in arms about
it the first season I my girl sensitive
and like honest
it's an important show and it talks
about things in like a really direct way
and I was really here for it I was like
fighting with people on the comments
like to defend it and they lost me on
the second season there was just it was
soaked you watch second season I'm still
trying to get through honestly there's a
scene I know if you've heard about it I
don't I have a spoiler alert I'm gonna
spoil okay that's good
boiler alerts if you haven't watched yet
I'm giving you 10 seconds to meet your
headphones there's a scene where this
kid is getting bullied and that does
happen for sure the kid who teachers get
hammered out good he's getting bleeding
some kids fall him to the bathroom like
beating the [ __ ] out of him and they
shove him over the toilet they shove a
broom up his ass so gruesome that's too
much and I'm not I'm not denying that it
doesn't happen right but I just think so
many kids are watching and like they're
like great idea right because kids are
idiot and honestly like I went to a
school where like there was bullying but
it's more like emotional bullying yeah
but it was never it which is also to
firm up advice yeah and that's whenever
L [ __ ] honestly it never even occurred
to me that like kids could do that and
like I feel like they're definitely a
lot of kids who didn't even know that
was a thing and now are like oh when I'm
beating someone up let me show up a
broom up there I here's the thing I do
think it's a show that should come with
like basically like a watch this with
your parents or parents watch this with
your kids and then so they have like a
word discretion but like kids parents
have no idea what kids are doing these
days I know well Debbie does not like
that job right so we did not talk about
that of course I know you know but like
when I was like on my like desktop
computer back in the day like I was like
I am a boys like that was a worst thing
I was doing like cuz it was not so much
information out there yes now like your
parents have no way to keep an eye on
their it's terrifying and also kids
can't escape the bullying yeah I feel so
bad fine being a kid is like the worst
show horse although I think that their
generation is so much better in terms of
like being socially conscious yes and
they're so open-minded so I feel like
they could actually maybe the bullying
will dissipate because of like what if
they're maybe in agreement with each
other's choices
what's yeah over you know I like go back
and forth between like really wanted to
be a kid and just longing for the days
where like you didn't have any worries
about like real things like financial
like job like yeah there's so much about
adult life that is so impossible but
then I also think about like sometimes
being a kid was the [ __ ] worse like
I'm at school reading right
tiny things like doing poorly on the
test with like literally you would get
sick to your stomach thinking that
people would find out about yourself
down a flight of stairs Fitz studied for
an AP History test right like there's so
much crazy and it's like now when you
think about it in retrospect it like
wasn't a big deal but like when you were
a kid you thought of it it's like the
biggest e on the world and you would
like to make yourself sick like so
sometimes I'm like no I don't ever want
to be a kid again
I don't want to go back there mom was my
mom's grounding me constantly right like
getting in trouble all the time interval
oh my god I need you I was like a bad
kid drink of course yeah
Margo what else did I have on the list
of things I want to talk to tell her
about Instagram stories and Stassi okay
let's talk about something and screams I
feel you're gonna you're gonna like
school me no no I'm not about it's
actually something funny um okay wait so
Stassi so you are good friends estas two
shorter Boehner proposal yeah he met her
super interesting I met her through work
at risk I interviewed her okay and then
I was going to go in on her cuz I
thought that she was the mean high
school bully that tortured me Swedish
princess I was ready to be like I really
hate you she's ready Jax and I know why
they dating better than Dave were not
dating but like it was like are they
aren't they but they were like we're
done um and she disarmed me immediately
and was like oh my god I love your show
what I was like stop you listen let's me
that's bad that's all it takes thirsty
yeah so oh so I was like then I was like
let's do besties uh-huh and then Patrick
came to me like a few months later was
like this crazy hot girl from a reality
show is DMing you Instagram and I said
dude are right and then the I mean and
then of course I encouraged a
relationship because they were dating
and and that's coming to this isn't a
better pump rules where she like she
quit what she was stupid for the show
and she would to New York she wasn't too
good for the show she felt so deeply
betrayed by everybody it was like you
know all the terrible things Jackson and
honestly as audience members we don't
even know that's the problem the
beginning companies reality she do I
will say Jax and I actually like Jax now
too
he is very protected yeah let me tell
you I'm so interested and so she really
like she went through it with him and
she's like how can you as my friends
like even having seen what he did yeah
not my side but then when the pranks his
stuff ends up being true they're all
like oh oh well right he was like hurt
to the core people in that cats aren't
necessarily like the moral compasses of
our generation but oddly they're like
so evolved I think they should be like
goals for all of us know a kid like
angrily
I mean really while they could create
real peace what are your thoughts on
Sheena dislike okay go wrongly and this
is from being her personal experience
yeah but also watch the show it is hard
to like know some of these people in
real life or have met them and then like
try and watch a TV show and you have
personal opinions on them as people she
knows I don't like her hmm here's my
thing every time like the crew comes to
New York and we're all together it's so
much fun except when Sheena is there
because she's there pushing food on her
plate trying to make it look like she's
eating so much taking a bajillion
pictures it's like it's not fun to be
around something like that and also she
pouts she sits in the middle of the
table and if everyone's not giving her
attention she pouts and not to sound
like oh my god I'm so important but like
right when Kristen Katie and Stassi are
here I don't get to see them all the
time and so they're like they're not
fawning all over me but they didn't do
you and scheana can and I know she
didn't as I talked [ __ ] about her on the
show so she won't let herself go there
so she just like sits there quietly sure
like get up and walk away from the table
and I'm like [ __ ] then don't [ __ ]
come nobody invited you anyway so I'm
not I don't like love her I mean I would
always give her a chance cuz when I went
for sauces birthday I change my mind
on so many people so that's what I was
gonna say is that I mean I for a while
only knew anything about scheana from
what I saw on the show and I saw on the
show was someone really annoying and
like vain and then we went out with chef
one night um when she didn't Shep had
sex
did they have sex remember Stephen McGee
but that wasn't cheating chef those
scheana and Carl Oh wrong show by the
way surrounded sac sorry sorry I I don't
know but I feel like they would probably
they definitely did but he was on watch
repins live with scheana and me Jackie
and Shep we're gonna hang out afterwards
and he invited scheana and like Michelle
Cheech like it was fun yes and you like
Shep love love life like him I've heard
things about him but I I met him for a
night and he was very fun so but I know
I'm in the sense that like we are good
friends and like I'm married and like
there's he's not trying to [ __ ] and I'm
lesbian so he raised there's like
talking about yes so like I feel like
he's there's no ulterior motive like he
really just like wants a chill we were
talking about like the book so I'm like
I was pretending to know what books he
was talking about like he's really like
a smart funny cool guy and he's like
really business like he's like this huge
plan for himself
and I just think he's really interesting
and it's just a good time and I can hang
out with anyone who's a good time and
Sheena came along um and I was like
dying as I talked to so much it about
her and like what and I just didn't like
her and she couldn't have been more
sweet and like we had a really good time
like really let go she was like drinking
a lot like what she don't like was she
trying really hard no we were in a dirty
dive bar no one was on their phones like
there was no one there who knew her like
it was an empty bar like we were just it
was just like real do you mean I'm so
but then a couple in sailor Shambala man
instagrams maybe okay see it's hard it
really is hard being a commentator on
all this here's the deal this is her
problem she takes herself too seriously
and she's a joke
she should be in on the joke and she'll
be syllable christened Dodie isn't
saying we all hated for being a saint
and then Kristin was like I'm sane and
we're all like we love you cuz just own
your own your [ __ ]
yep we're all flawed philosophy
beautifully oh yeah like if she was just
like I'm an idiot with boys I am like
the stereotypical crazy girl and like I
took myself to see her so sometimes and
could laugh that yeah she would actually
be very cool there's so much to be said
for someone who can laugh at themselves
and people who take themselves too
seriously like I just don't have time
for unfollowed you like that is like
such a move on both my accounts whoa
whoa she was sending a message she was
really mad how do you think he said um I
don't think it was one thing in
particular I just think we hung out and
then like someone alerted her to all the
things I said in the past you know dad
so people do yeah it's like shitty
what's the call dumb retro actively
right but see that's the thing is she
could've been like well I met her hung
out with her and I and and what's in the
past breath and I'm always cool right
I'm always like the first person to say
that I was wrong like when me and Jackie
um we're recapping real houses in New
Jersey we hated Margaret Joseph's really
and just because like just what former
we knew about the show and stealing your
pigtails sagina just come on our show
and she was like making us she was
rubbing us up too like Ziggy hate very
convincing yes she was making us hate
Margaret and then like we got pitched
Margaret more like of course we'll take
her and like we were freaking out cuz
like we don't really like like her and
like honestly I've never met a more
genuinely lovely amazing woman my entire
life we're still friends today she
invites us her house she sent me such a
sweet message when our show got canceled
like I will go I will fight to the death
I will trial by combat for Margot Joseph
if anyone has anything [ __ ] bad to
say about her exactly and as you think
that whole Jewish thing was really blown
out of proportion I was the most
horrible thing Ziggy I am obsessed sick
he should be so punished for that
somehow I am a rounded person to like
speculate anti-semitism if I think
something even like remotely reeks of
like bigotry I'm like this is
you know in fact and cement even then I
was like alright this is a little erotic
Ziggy wet wait even her dad was like
seigi no ha ha ha it's like you know you
can't just you know you can't draw that
one out you you have responsibility ya
throw that card around because you're
the unit when it's [ __ ] abort because
it's very real sometime you know else
did that who Kyle Richards go way back
to when the witch yes put the start I
already say but the thing is so she's
allowed to mock that woman's I'm not
religious into being a Wiccan or is it
paganism yes but you know she was like
you're a witch do you read right on a
broomstick break imagine if you took the
[ __ ] you're saying to this woman right
applied it did you use them or any other
religion she would that's so basically
like holding what's the word for
anti-semitism for witches anta which ism
ante which ism yes so Kyle's Nancy which
yeah and then she queues at which I mean
you sound like a witch right now I know
because I'm so mad about know that's a
good point that's how I feel sometimes
that Scientology cuz like it's a cult
and it's so discussing but but it is
technically a religion they get a tax
break like I'm with you so I get nervous
because I'm like one day we're all gonna
go back and it's gonna be like oh my god
they said what about alright exactly I
told you right like it's gonna be but
like I know what it is I know it's like
this discussing cult that was like takes
advantage of people and steals our money
but at the same time it is a religion so
the way that like we as a community like
speak about Scientology is kind of
[ __ ] up it is I mean it's not really
it's not cool and also what about this
Hillsong thank you okay there we gets
new Scientology okay Hillsong is so
controversial and someone did to put
that in our group and people really
upset by it because ever two things
there are people who are followers of
our show and are so involved in the
Hillsong really and they love it they
say well change their life like they
just I really feel so connected to God
so spiritual they have this huge
community of people that they're making
the Christianity cool again they are
they are Flocka from orange is the new
black
yeah she is in Hillsong couple cards
came on our show mmm carlins he started
it though she the priest that's like
pretty like okay so he started Hillsong
or he's a founding member he's Justin
Bieber's pastor now he's getting on the
celebrities involved and they've reached
so much money from like Justin Bieber oh
yeah oh yeah so he came on the show we
did not know what to expect cuz like
we're Jewish so like we're like this
doesn't apply to us but like well
talk about it I don't know like is this
like a second coming of Scientology
right right
firstly shut up in like a lot of jacket
and glasses and he was like so hot and
we realize got to ask he was so hot we
were like I'd like the only love how
people anything yeah I also object to
who knew remark not inclusive um and
what do you say he say anything crazy
like he was really just like really
excited about his religion really
excited about his community he's making
money and we were like we're Jewish like
we were just like no but like he's like
there's a place for you like he was very
interesting but almost to the point like
concern and then like we hit it off so
well he took our numbers like we were
setting each other's weight you're gonna
die I would thank you all do know
actually after chatting we were at
comodo actually no me and Ben we're in
Miami who went to komodo for dinner
which is like every it's the restaurant
like everyone goes to me it's like call
the publicist to get a reservation was
so crazy I'm gonna go and we're out and
I see my friend Simon and he's there
with his boyfriend who me and Ben know
really well so we just like merge tables
let me sat with them and like they were
sitting in like the cooler section cuz
like he's cooler than me
and we were sitting and then right
across from us sits down hailey past her
and like to other people and also just I
know Lala and Randall no no no she was
at the table next step not she was just
does an interesting footnote could not
love Lala more same oh my god so I
really want is my friend Simon knows
hailey so like we went over and then I
wanted to like be cool too so I saw
pastor Carl and I was like Carl he was
like so weird and like pretend like he
didn't know me and I was like shut up so
embarrass and I was like I literally was
like in front of Kelly ball when like
Houser like I was being like I came up
from behind a game like a big [ __ ] oh I
need your brain up was like hi and I was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
wait he's wait it's like hi or he was hi
ha oh hi so then I'm dying
wait then I'm like mortified to me and
Simon are leading in Simon's like I
can't believe that I'm like me now I'm
so bad if I came for like wait it gets
worse comes running out of the
restaurant pastor Carl he said oh I
couldn't place you but I'm so famous and
bridge at his store no yeah I don't
remember but I'm sorry I totally forgot
how are you give me like a huge hug it's
like I'm gonna miss you the six I'm like
oh but you didn't want to say hi to me
friend hailey Bowman I know that game I
played that game before I've done this
other
can you believe that he called race
printed Simon was like that is crazy why
also know people that work for him
like they would they were like in the
beginning stages and they're like high
high up and I actually like them they're
cool but I hate people their best
friends with so and then that's also I
don't know I'm like I said I'm not gonna
like start like making negative comments
on people's religious practices yeah
because that's not a cool thing to do no
but like I'm concerned it's all I'll say
yeah I have a case
have some concerns two more things that
we could do two more things I want to
skip this is the long as ever we really
need to wrap it up okay you know Patrick
very well you introduced Stassi to him
what did you think about his depiction
on the show not good but is that what
he's like that's what he's like he's
pissed okay you know I mean like he he
definitely I think he wanted to let Lisa
know that he thought she was [ __ ]
and he did right you know and I don't
disagree with him she is both I don't
agree with the way he handled it but I
know where he was like I was watching it
from his mental standpoint going like oh
I know exactly what's going on the
reason Stassi was all like what's
because she was like oh [ __ ] here we go
this is gonna be the end of us and I'd
like that was never one thing it's like
took him so long to get in the show and
this is what's gonna end it so I think
that we were seeing somebody that was
worried what was gonna happen was
exactly what happened and you know it
was honestly never gonna work out it's
like he was so against the one thing
that is like her life and I talked to
both of them about that like I'm like
you can't you know you can't be with
somebody and then accept him to change
it's just not real but so Carter he's on
the show and like no one cares he
could've just came in and been quiet and
like been uninteresting and then they
wouldn't have won I think he fell I
think you who knows what prodding went
on with users
I do feel he was kind of like like a
tiger in a cage
III don't know I don't want to say setup
but I think he definitely was given bait
and maybe took it yeah all right well
that is our show
thank God we went an hour and a half
over because we still don't want to talk
about and Taylor is back tomorrow I know
I'm like I could go from a live no
Wednesday
tell us your chain tomorrow Wednesday I
have a blank spot I haven't decided who
I'm choosing yet and then Thursday B of
the point sky Brian Kelly which I'm so
[ __ ] excited about because me and the
points guy tonight are going to the VMAs
he got me a ticket so we're gonna yeah
I'm we're going to like a concert
like we have a full night I got a
jumpsuit so we're gonna be here on
Thursday recapping it all and then I
have two shows in New Jersey on Thursday
night I believe there's some VIP tickets
left for the second one girl - job calm
and then I'm taking Friday off because I
haven't taken a summer Friday yet and
I'm gonna get home super late from New
Jersey and I'm just not in the mood but
that's it I really hope you guys enjoy
today's show we're back tomorrow make
sure to follow Taylor on Instagram
Taylor's tracker right at Taylor's
tracker spelled the normal way yeah and
Telus trekker calm if you enjoy the show
and you want to listen to Taylor every
day you do Monday through Friday 2 hours
8 to 10 live and people can listen live
radio and they can also just test it out
if they're not sure if they want to
commit taste of Taylor podcast yeah
which is where on Wednesday our
interview will be on yeah it's a really
good interview really good it's very
in-depth but while still being funny and
cool and relatable thank you all so much
for tuning in to the Millenial morning
show the morning toes for live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on Facebook and YouTube so make sure you
like us on Facebook subscribe to us on
YouTube and then for those commuters out
there we're also available in the
podcast store at the morning toast if
you have an Android you can also listen
on soundcloud I think that's all the
announcements that I have my tickets to
camp toast bye
you